uh we're continuing to track what's
happening with this omicron variant
and um booster mandates are starting
the united kingdom is setting new
records it is an explosion of
information and of panic
and i understand the worry and i also
still don't know that it is warranted on
the basis of what we know about omicron
so let's go through a few different
aspects here
businesses many employers and
universities are now saying
fully vaccinated means three shots not
two
now however serious omicron is the early
data the early data
is that
if you have three shots you are
significantly less likely to get a
symptomatic infection of omicron than if
you have two shots now on asymptomatic
we don't yet really know on
effectiveness on against serious uh
illness or death we're still getting
information it seems three shots are
somewhat better but three shots seem
significantly better than two
against omicron
against symptomatic illness so that's
really important so the metropolitan
opera yesterday said
if you want to be an eligible audience
member or an employee you need that
third shot a georgetown nyu some private
colleges have said you're going to need
your third shot number of universities
where i know people uh uh working say
that when you come back for the spring
semester you've got to have that third
shot the nfl is requiring coaches and
staff to get booster shots by december
27th and the real question here
is
what is actually going on
with the omicron variant and i know we
continue to say
it's early we still need more data we
still need to wait it continues to be
that on average if you get the omicron
variant you are less likely to get
really really sick
by virtue of being more contagious which
it appears to be
the burden on society can still be large
and we are seeing even advance of
omicron being the reason even still with
delta we're starting to see
hospitals in different states
increasingly fill up so that's one
aspect of what's going on um the cdc has
issued a forecast that cases weekly are
going to be up to 1.3 million by
christmas day
and that deaths are going to surge 73
percent to over 15 000 a week
when and as omicron becomes the dominant
strain and again some people hear that
and they say
well hold on a second um if it's less
serious why would deaths go up and again
you could have something that's half as
serious but three times as contagious
and you would still see deaths go up 50
percent i mean it's very very crude math
it doesn't exactly work that way but
that's basically the way that it is
in the meantime the uk is seeing
absolutely record cases
uh a number of different countries are
seeing really really insane numbers
and the good news if there is any in the
uk is that while the cases are going up
dramatically as omicron takes over
deaths due to covid are actually down
over the last two weeks now that may
reverse what what's the what's the
possible counterpoint to
it's very spreadable but less severe the
counterpoint would be
what if there's more of a delay before
you get really sick in other words we i
think at one point the average interval
between infection and death was 17 days
at one point it doesn't really matter
but at one point it was roughly 17 days
is it possible that omicron causes mild
disease for i don't know five weeks
and then you get really sick and die
doctors say it's possible but it's not
very likely so that that's the good news
so far
uh that we can point to
um lastly
the white house there's been this
question of
would the u.s shut down again to the
extent that the u.s ever did shut down
i think the answer is no for for a
couple of different reasons unless there
were to be a more severe variant which
we don't seem to have at this point in
time number one
at the state level there are very few
states at this point that seem willing
to do anything even remotely
approximating a shutdown that's number
one
uh number two
the white house is saying we are not
going to do that we are not going to
have sweeping shutdowns
um but we are seeing signs that
certainly raise questions as to what the
policy should be the hospital's becoming
overrun events being postponed some
colleges and universities already going
back to remote so there are signs
but the white house insists it's not
going to happen again if you get your
third shot and that actually is 70
effective at preventing symptomatic
illness
and this is a more spreadable but less
serious variant
if people do the right things you
shouldn't have to shut down if the
shutdowns become a real
possibility
um it would overwhelmingly be because a
lot of people aren't doing the things
that are available to us to do let me
know your thoughts what do you think
will happen in the next one to two
months
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy dot com
slash pacman the link is right
underneath this video